[Música]
Bueno, el arco continuo no siempre está por debajo.
en el betis 4 ibm rosa al minuto con el
compañero michael camilleri director de
programa de estado de re es decir diálogo
asesores gubernamentales internacionales
y Barack Obama puede quedarse en Francia 24
la empresa de exhibición dirigida a América
Latina te esperarán como resultado
la seleccion estaba en unidos que
significa migración interna del
relación de una religión o entorno
y el llamado de un poco de Biden y
El candidato emo casillas apunta a la gente.
La cuestión migratoria como relato de
El esquema está claramente en un segundo.
Doveier señala que este tranvía es Hinckley
querido a una continuación
si la política en la pantalla de Sisto es que el
El primer gobierno es claramente de
celiaco ansioso lucio campania y parece que hay
presidencia para defender quién migra a
presidente siopara entre la idea de unaprol y
movimiento visto el último pss consecuencia el
texto con separación familiar si y
Yo a si mismo y gasté cualquier
similar
es el caso de los jóvenes es claro que
ne pródigo amos un episodio de barbilla
enmascaramiento de la subvención spi y si se detiene
La acción deportiva y el experimento diario.
en la presidencia al párr.
Richard y la política es importante.
tiene una propuesta para 4 niños
Centroamérica es el patrimonio de
gobierno
lidiar con atacar el corte y el
migración señor es para luchar contra la pobreza
la corrupción perseguirá es la que obliga a
Cyrano es residente en Suecia, si es que lo hay.
la diosa dura sin saberlo
ku y la crisis venezolana también
llevar a cabo y en el corto y serio tiempo que es
tallo picante pegado que tal vez asi
ganau hayden es tu responsabilidad
de política exterior
cuando entonces vicepresidente colom e
tengan cuidado en venezuela del 77 nunca pero si yo
luego claro para rel
nicolas maduro singh de calor y el
presión y tanto ritmo como papá
Maduro y Venezuela van al Cesar
es política nacida en un gobierno
biden es probablemente el ser masa
multilateral va a priori sar al
En la empresa la política ha despertado el siligo.
es con dias hacer silas el otro archivo
erika latina sistema de la unión europea
Parece que puedes conseguir una tarjeta de autobús y es una subida.
finalmente democrático y a la selección
de libros y en Venezuela es como vamos a ir
unilateralmente y cuál es el
presente y el plan de negocio en el que se basa
por ejemplo con la mirada como sabemos
Apuesto que son respetados
Para lograrlo la miró como si fuera algún tipo
es claramente mss acuerdo se pone
la exposición importa la protección
depresivo en el ambiente fernés
caos a solistas a la cabeza y manga o
calentando fuerte el slalom entre impuestos y en
congreso y esto es algo que se espera desde hace mucho tiempo
lejos con biden quién sabe si disposición y
si va nasser completo y es manera
estricto perdemos el acuerdo con canadá y
asientos de doctor y cariño
a michael cammalleri directo del
programa de estado y diálogo
interamericana y ex consejera de
gobierno pero estrella polar Sé quién es Toulouse
sí inacabado schon de france 24 de
albergue sibit amos para continuar con
mason esta pagina web el punto petrolero
información de france24 puntocom en
cuatro mascolo luego me recosté sobre esto
También es muy importante si el
Situación económica internacional y nacional.
últimos tramos inacabados en los que basamos
como se forma es
[Música]